do you think you're well prepared for
your next interview
you surely might be with your subject
however a few other common questions
asked by an interviewer seem easy but
are a little tricky
this video on the top 10 interview
questions and answers will help you
strategically craft an
app answer for each of these questions
and help you
answer them smoothly it is not necessary
to memorize these answers
still it is advisable to build your
answers around the tips we will give you
here
based on your skills and experience of
course
by doing so you will feel more confident
and stress-free in your interview
so let's begin and lay out the most
commonly asked interview questions that
will play a huge role in determining
your future
one one of the first questions you can
expect in an interview is tell me about
yourself
although this seems to be easy there are
a few tips to remember while answering
this
through this question highlight your
education experience and hobbies
don't get too personal while answering
this simultaneously
make sure to highlight your qualities
another question that is commonly asked
is what is your strength and weakness
this is generally asked to check if you
as an individual can identify what you
lack and at the same time
understand what you think is a positive
trait that you own
we suggest you break this answer into
two parts and speak about your strengths
first
do not be overly confident while listing
out your strengths as it can always
backfire
you a few good strengths that an
interviewer seems fit will be
flexibility teamwork attention to detail
and so on
you can add whatever else you feel is
correct for you however
don't keep the list too long and brag
about yourself
coming to your weaknesses you don't have
to be very hard on yourself
think of a particular weakness that also
seems to be beneficial in some way
for example you could say that your
attention to detailed trait can at times
be a disadvantage as you tend to spend
more time
and deep dive when issues crop up so
this won't be just a weakness since it
carries a positive sight as well
there are instances where the
interviewers ask you if you
have overcome your weaknesses make sure
to mention that you are working on it
and trying to improve
three another tricky question can be why
do you want this job
it can also be rephrased as why should
we hire you
what interests you about this role this
is an answer that you can ace if you
plan it well
through your answer you can get an
opportunity to show what you know about
the job you are applying for
and the company be accurate with your
answers
list a few aspects of the job role that
appeals to you the most
and speak about ways to contribute to
this role
carrying out good research on the
company and understanding the job
description will help you answer this
question
mention specific points that will
convince the hiring manager that you are
a good fit for this particular job
make sure that you don't sound arrogant
at the same time not too modest
in reality you might just want the job
to fill a career gap for the money
however it is best if you don't say that
and instead polish your answers around
these tips
four so the next question you can expect
is why did you leave your last job
this question might seem a little
awkward and can get you
job seekers get nervous but don't worry
we'll give you a few tips to maneuver
through this
so if you were fired from your last job
it is best if you own up to it
and tell them what you learned from that
experience and how you have to overcome
those issues right now
you might think it's best not to tell
the truth here but that's a bad
idea as companies can always do a
background check and know the reality
and when that happens it won't leave a
good impression
we all make mistakes and hence it is
okay to own up to it as long as you are
fixing those mistakes right now
so in cases where you have voluntarily
left your previous job
explain why you can mention points like
you were looking for a different
challenge
and indirectly map it with a new
position you're interviewing for
you could also say how the new company
you are interviewing for has been one of
the dream companies and so on
if there are other reasons for it like
budget cuts or economic issues
you can mention those as well however at
no point should you be speaking wrong of
your last company or your previous
management don't make statements like
how boring or mundane your previous job
was
try to answer this question with
positivity only
five another question that could be
asked is what is your greatest
accomplishment at work here you can pick
an accomplishment that displays the
right set of qualities that the company
values and those that match the role
you're interviewing for
pick a single accomplishment that you
feel will have the most impact
another way this question can be asked
is describe a difficult work situation
and how you handled it
this question is asked to assess how
well you work in a tough situation
in your approach for this you need to
have a well thought out success story
ready
think of an instance wherein you
successfully dealt with a problem all by
yourself
take a story that exhibits your skills
to be an asset to the job you're
interviewing for
first mention the situation then move on
to the task and action you carried out
finally speak about how fruitful the
result was
you could speak about a situation
wherein your boss was away
and how you single-handedly handled
issues of a client
who was on the verge of leaving and so
on
basically through your answer the
interviewer wishes to see how fit you
are to handle any problem that could
arise
make sure to be precise with your answer
display how passionate you are
and that you are a problem solver six
moving on to the next question how do
you handle stress and pressure
don't fall under pressure while
answering this question and instead
respond calmly
to begin with don't say that you don't
get stressed as fascinating as that
sounds it is
unbelievable since we are all humans
indeed
being overconfident this way will make
the interviewer suspicious
every job comes with its own kind of
tension and pressure
this question is asked to know how work
pressure affects you and your approach
to it
the best way to plan this answer is by
providing examples of how you've handled
work pressure and stress in the past
and how that's molded you for the better
for example
speak about how good pressure can help
you you could say having pressure keeps
you motivated and more productive
mention that the best way you overcome
stress is by creating a well-planned
schedule that will help you complete the
assigned project before the deadline
this shows that you turn stress into
action and take it positively to
accomplish your tasks
seven our seventh question is about your
goals
you can be asked where do you see
yourself in five years
your answer to this question analyzes
your commitment to the company
don't mention how you wish to be the ceo
of the company you are interviewing for
that makes it look too unrealistic be
grounded while answering this question
for example speak of how you want to
break the next five years into phases
in the first couple of years mention how
you want to learn everything about your
job and acquire new skills
after which in the next few years
mention how you wish to be in a position
to help other team members and the
company with your skills and the
acquired knowledge
this way you are showing that you wish
to learn and grow at the same time
another question that can be asked on
the same lines is what are your future
goals
this is also asked to determine whether
you will stick with a company in the
long term
this question also analyzes your
ambitions and how you forecast your
career
you could answer this in the same way as
the mentioned previously
before answering do try to understand
what you want for yourself and see if
the job role you're applying for helps
you reach your ultimate desired goals
8 our next question is what can you do
for us that other candidates can
this question is asked bluntly to
distinguish yourself from other
candidates
it is not very simple to answer this
question hence plan it beforehand
this question can be answered on the
lines of your strength and how you stand
out from the rest of the pack
at no time should you be critical of
other candidates all you need to do is
speak about yourself
emphasize any special certifications
that you have your prior industry
experience or
you could speak about your strong
interpersonal skills
in the end you can mention that the
combination of these skills can add
great value to the team you will be
working with
remember to keep it precise and don't
compare yourself with other candidates
and instead
highlight your qualities and skills nine
our next question is
what salary are you seeking or what are
your salary expectations
this has to check if your salary
expectations match the company's amount
budgeted for the role you are applying
for
to be able to answer this you need to
know your worth hence
research the salary range from your role
in your area and have an idea about it
before replying to this question
for example if you give a range that is
way higher or lower than the market
value
it looks like you are unaware of your
worth you could wish to ask for a higher
side of the market range
however you must clearly show that you
are flexible and salary can be
negotiable
you could also be careful and instead
ask for the employer what range they are
looking to pay someone your background
typically has
this way you will know what the employer
has in his or her mind
and speak around that 10 our final
question is very common
do you have any questions for me usually
the interviewer concludes by asking you
if you have any questions for them
now is the right time for you to clarify
your doubts and ask questions
make sure to ask good and relevant
questions this displays the seriousness
you have towards the job
firstly if you have any doubts or
questions in mind regarding the job role
and your day-to-day responsibilities
feel free to ask secondly it is good if
you ask about the company's culture
lastly you can ask questions regarding
the opportunities you will be getting
for the professional development in this
particular role
it is of utmost importance that you are
convinced about the job role and its
growth to go ahead this is the time for
you to decide as well if you want this
job or not
based on the interviewer's reply you can
decide if that particular job is good
or not for your career avoid asking too
many questions and questions about
off-work activities
remember that every question you ask
shows your seriousness
hence avoid asking silly time wasting
questions
so those were the top 10 commonly asked
interview questions
now you know the kind of questions you
have to review and prepare for before
your next interview
pause and think about it before you
respond to any questions
keep these tips in mind and frame your
answers accordingly
following these tips will surely help
you stand out from the crowd
that brings us to the end of this video
on the top 10 interview questions and
answers we hope these tips are helpful
to all of you job seekers out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching this video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]